so because it is international women's
month everybody gets a month and even
though we can't decide what a woman is
uh Jill Biden Dr Jill Biden and
Secretary of State Anthony blinken were
giving out some International women
Awards and uh yeah one of them included
giving an award to a dude enjoy
[Applause]
zams refused job opportunities subjected
to violence and rejected by her family
but in the face of these challenges she
worked to end violence and
discrimination against the lgbtqi plus
community in Argentina
yeah
you could see that blinken wanted to go
for tongue there couldn't you Brendan he
was definitely making the move
well what better way to accept this
thing as a woman than for blinking to
just go full on tongue make out with it
uh it's so we're literally fighting with
the devil this is what what is happening
in society and it's so infuriating
because how long how long did women
fight to just get a you know an evening
playing field for years and then when
they finally get it
in comes the Democrats with a wrecking
ball like Miley Cyrus just ruining it
and just destroying everything that it
is about being a woman you know what's
interesting I I feel like we never talk
about trans men it's always trans women
that is a thing so that that's very
curious to me and it's it's such a slap
in the face I really I I really hope I
become a dad one day but I really hope
it's not to a girl because I don't know
how I'm gonna explain all this craziness
to her one day it's just so sad
well you know joking aside for just a
second my personal take on this is I
don't care how someone chooses to live
once they are an adult but when we are
pushing this stuff on kids it's a
different thing and to your point we are
giving awards to biological men in the
name of women so it's an assault on
women and I would say the trans thing is
also an assault on gay people because
they've because gay the gay rights
movement was always about equality and
now it's being replaced with oh you
better literally chop your genitals off
and become the opposite sex because
somehow that's more tolerable than
actually being gay Sarah you you've done
a lot with the the trans situation
because of the drag queen shows in Texas
so I'll just kind of throw it to you
there and go whichever way you want to
go well
I have a couple things
they hear you know it's fascinating that
for all this time the left wanted to
talk about the patriarchy the patriarchy
the patriarchy is taking things from
women can you think of a more
representative example of the patriarchy
than men literally replacing Us in
everything it's maddening all these
feminists that are like yay I'm so happy
that men are replacing us and taking our
Awards and our scholarships and they're
invading our bathrooms they are
literally a re this is the Erasure of
women and I don't understand the radical
feminist who as Brendan pointed out
fought for so long to to you know for
what they called equality just to sit
back and watch all of these men take
over they think that you know slapping
on a bunch of makeup and putting on some
fake breasts is going to make them a
woman I just it's so maddening to me if
you'd like more sane takes on our insane
World check out our direct message clips
playlist and if you want to watch more
full episodes of our live round tables
watch our round tables playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell